we are back exactly
I can literally just as lovely like a
reptile by Motorhead off of Ace of
Spades I could just oh man I can't in
the morning first thing I want to hear
when I wake up is [ __ ] love me like a
reptile would you're Metallica t-shirt
yo yeah that was when they did the
Apollo I wear the shirt bless you
sweetie
yeah they did the Apollo years ago the
Sirius XM has this great series they do
of bands that have never been in the
Apollo mostly white artists and I've
seen Metallica there which was so
amazing to watch away and what is this
show with people who well the Apollo
Theater in Harlem is it's a legendary
black venue and every Oh major
performance played their 25th street in
Harlem and so you know it's a legendary
place and you know there's a lot of
people that would never play there so
it's a thousand seats and these are all
bands that you don't get into a thousand
seat venue but I've seen McCartney there
I've seen Bruce Springsteen there I've
seen Guns and Roses there Metallica
there because they all want to do this
legendary venue I did not see who was
just there all you two did it yeah a
thousand seat venue yeah because they
all want to work the Apollo serious it's
a legendary it's like it's like I want
to do the Comedy Cellar you know it's
more legendary than the celibates the
same energy of other hey I want to do
this place I mean the Apollo is a
different world yeah it's just it's it's
every black performer who we know whose
faith has come through there
I open for Amy's HBO special I forgot
she shot there yeah Chris Rock wider
black audience it was all white which
was weird cuz you pull up in your car
he's just all these white blond chicks
waiting to go into the Apollo it looks
like a porno or something you know and
it was while looking out cuz it's tiny
it's small and then the balconies right
up on you when it's all just like how
theater yeah I'm seeing shows there was
it was incredible watching because the
acoustics are perfect to go there I've
never performed there rich vos this is I
remember when rich Voss did Def Jam he
was the first white comedian on Def Jam
and I believe that was shot at maybe I'm
wrong it wasn't him alone I thought it
was he might have said that yeah I tried
to be precise Jim I mean when I talk
about rich Ross's career precision is
the case
yeah and you guys were talking before
during the break just briefly about
hanging out with mostly comics that's
who I'm more comfortable with too and
it's not that I don't think other people
get me I just I I don't care about their
job days I don't want to hear it I just
feel good with comics I just feel I
don't know it's it's it's weird it's
selfish it's not nice to the first time
I heard that I was like when I heard a
comedian saying I can't hang out with
normal people this is judgmental but
then you're like yeah I know what are
you saying I know I know it's awful
course it's not even just that they're
normal it's just we like to analyze and
talk about the weird little intricacies
of life and they go what are you talking
about I'm talking about my order at
lunch I'm like no no I know but anyway
the ketchup comes in these packets or
like who cares I'm like this is my life
well you just you're getting judged but
you also I also find that they expect
what bothers me is they expect as a
comic they just expect you to be a
certain like the things that they find
amusing like a lot of times I don't um
or a lot of times they expect you to be
what their impression of a comic is know
most miserable douches of course and you
don't want to you don't want to have to
explain that they would get it but you
just mean what you don't want to explain
that like that that's not my personality
yeah yeah yeah I'm not on all the time
it you heard that line at the zoo and
algae you know you go to the zoo and the
Lions just laying there and they're like
what the hell I thought I'd come see a
lion to be tearing up a grizzly bear or
climbing a tree or something thing it's
just laying there and that's like comics
we're just laying there you know we're
not gonna be always ripping apart a
carcass and also I'm not expecting
something when I talk to you I just talk
to you and we build you know yes without
wanting it it's the right way we are I'm
not expecting you to make me love for
all this great joke no I'll just go
through something with you and that's
yeah I don't know we're just a bunch of
pretentious but take any job is like
that I think I think know yours play
like a comfortable other lawyers because
they can talk about their lives
uncertain I don't think so they don't
get something from it they don't come
back home and say oh I I spoke this
lawyer and now oh my god I can't wait to
see him again but when I saw mark this
morning I was like
great there's a comedian I feel good I
don't know I mean I get I haven't done
another job in so many years
I'm a lawyer I can tell you did you
actually study law a lot of comics do no
there was not even a joke just just a
lie you just fly it out alive I was a
lion before you were in a zoo there you
go laying there you just fired out
[ __ ] and I believe there's a lot of
comics and Dan Neiderman I think went to
law school I mean Geraldo yeah
the Harvard Law Dmitri of course there's
a few guys that actually became lawyers
and then just said [ __ ] the only one who
looked like a lawyer is manaman no he
look similar no John Mulaney
it might even lost him no but he looks
like a lawyer yeah he's a handsome
lawyer
very chic yes good-looking guy it talks
like a lawyer great head of hair yeah he
does have a [ __ ] goddamn good head of
hair on him that bastard yeah he's good
at all luckily he hates himself I hope
so yeah yeah Delaney hate him so I
assumed I would hope he does most of us
do
yeah hate ourselves not him yeah I know
that's fine I don't and I'm hoping he
does tell us with the hair you had a lot
of hair before no I was never great was
a bad girl my hair is fine I had [ __ ]
I have back I you know wicked cowlick oh
my hair stinks I I would do this thing
with it because it would looks like a
McDonald's M when I was younger I used
to take bobby pins and bobby pin pin the
front when it was wet bobby pins up here
a girl puts in her hair to try to uh oh
yeah like these are my hair that's my
hair uh that's me is a junior in high
school some cute kid Wow but you can't
see the cowlicks go to the other one the
cover of despicable right there that
record that's that's actually my
sophomore high school gross yeah James
Norton I really wasn't unbeatable
lumpish guys in jail this guy yeah what
a creep right too bad they hadn't
thought of school shooting men no I know
there was no social media to push yes
that's me no that's Ralphie May that was
my first I was HBO 2005 or 2006 like a
half-hour look at the chins yeah yeah I
was a pig exactly I was a real long
you man so many cheese yeah I was a
disgusting the katsu only two yeah see
ya my hair was a disaster now I'm a good
I had the hair transplant I'm coming out
you're lying tell the truth no just a
little bit here
people don't say and I say I don't care
I would not have noticed actually there
was it plugged it wasn't like Anthony my
old working partner Anthony had died but
I would never do it again
idea was just a little bit here it was
did they take it from the back of your
head how'd they get the yeah there's no
other place they'd take it from the back
your head yeah I couldn't I would not
have seen it I wouldn't either
yeah maybe I'm lying too but that's the
genius is it looks a little thinning so
it looks real you would never question
it like Steve Martin has a piece but he
has a piece that's balding that's the
genius it really is so you go you go
obviously real cuz it says lime perfect
they like everyone you know when I
started have gray hair I was like I'm
getting old and everyone is everyone is
telling you
oh no but look at George Clooney like
right if you can really refer some
fairies yeah it's so easy but and then I
read I made a research the to have the
scholar George Clooney has to do a real
job doing the right collar right what
does he have a busy guy all the way but
people are trying to get that look
you're saying yeah yeah that's funny I'm
sure you ask someone do it though he
just sits there in a chair and probably
just script about somebody with you know
somebody forming the liquids and the
trailer no yeah that's that's a women
like that they like that sexy he's still
young enough to reproduce but he's old
enough to be a gentleman who's
established yeah that's perfect man yeah
I'd wait that again he's you know again
look at his [ __ ] he is who he is
great head you know if you have if you
didn't [ __ ] carcass on his head we're
gonna [ __ ] him I mean he's Clooney yeah
here she won the Golden Girls years ago
oh yeah that was a funny ass show he was
on facts of life and was he yeah he was
the repairman because look wait wait
come to the right right it almost looks
better when it's dark and gray yeah dad
really wants to [ __ ] George Clooney
so on
yeah I didn't lose on the facts of life
what the fact you are that's an American
show it was about Starling Charlotte Rae
who international star and of course the
Lisa Walter is Blair and uh who is a Kim
fields as 2d I don't know
and something else it come it was a
sitcom she was it was an alarm oh god
that's right what a hunk look at that
yeah look at a chin that was an offshoot
from Diff'rent Strokes yes
didn't she play like [ __ ] I the the
made for the Drummond's Jesus Jim well I
know your stuff you know yeah it's cool
I can't believe I can't find a woman to
[ __ ] me with that information how are
women not lining up to drink out of my
mom that's facts of life chatter we're
looking at pictures of George Clooney
when he was really young beautiful locks
uh yeah
oh yeah yeah do you are you a single guy
now are you not a single you are how
long you been single on and off it's
weird I don't know me too
do you like it or no I mean I just date
I like it I like it I just don't want to
be sad
yeah what do you Center good luck I
don't know I just I don't know I I don't
want to get surprised by that now I'm
okay I'm good I'm good you wanna get
surprised by the the sadness the the you
know oh yeah but you shattered when you
with somebody when you break up with
them oh and you're single
sometimes when I'm single if it's too
long I will need you know that sure but
now I'm good it's great do you go on
like that's why I go to to comedy club
and it's great yeah yeah you get to hang
with other comics and this and you know
what I when I have a date I ask her to
come to the cellar is it's crazy I know
just because I want to hang out I want
to sit with her I wanted you talk and
then be at the comedy club I don't want
to go in the restaurant and you know one
two one oh wow is I can a lot of
pressure it's a lot of pressure and I'm
gonna get bored I would much rather do
that and I'll bring a girl to sell her
for she knows me but like early on I
want nothing to do with bringing them to
the to a club because
just drop you know you see you have
friends there and I don't know you I
don't know it could be a lot of pressure
as you say yeah I don't know the seller
cuz I'm gonna go up on stage and I gonna
bomb I don't need the pressure of her or
if she doesn't watch she's upstairs with
your [ __ ] goon animal friends what's
the [ __ ] like yeah yeah if she comes
with friends that that's a problem
okay no no no first no he means are our
friends talk to her while you're on
stage that scares me yeah that really
bothers me too yeah I want nothing to do
with a bunch of people I know talking to
a girl I'm dating no because nothing
good can come of it not one thing
Troy you understand right do you want
your friends talking to a girl you're
trying to [ __ ] do because they're not
they're not gonna help no they're not
even they trying to help Oh even to
trying to help it's obvious and super
stupid I know I know
also it's great yeah have you seen his
act yeah exactly
Mike is so funny you'll see yeah I mean
now they're gonna go he's a hack I can't
believe you're dating him yeah some guys
are just [ __ ] blockers yeah but [ __ ]
blocking it's not something that's turn
I haven't heard in a long time or used
because I haven't Lee brought anybody
into the Comedy Cellar but there's some
guys are awful Oh [ __ ] awful yes they
say dumb [ __ ] just and you're like eh
you are you are you a stupid person or
are you just consciously being a [ __ ]
I think it's an insecurity thing you
know they're like oh I'm gonna ruin this
guy's night yeah I guess so no I'm on
and off I go out like you know it's like
I wanna tinder in these other apps I
don't do that well you do Riya I was on
Riya [ __ ] Riya why it's amazing great
looking people yeah so what sort of
Cosmopolitan magazine no one [ __ ] me
from there either really strike out
horribly on right just put your account
balance I love the job they have let's
do where the show this I got right this
woman her job was vegan chef writer and
personal trainer damn in LA how can he
do that there are some hot girls on Riya
though yeah but
Afton much you know yeah my last one was
some girl saying hello to me
August 17 Wow
dude I'm this year yeah alright that's a
month you're on it I was I'm seeing a
lady now but I was I was dead I was
swinging baby there was one girl I
talked to miss something but it's not
it's like it's a it's a game no yeah and
it's comics we have it so easy cuz you
get the date and you bring it to the
cellar you have a good set you're in
this you can cut through all the
[ __ ] but they're never here they're
never where you are have you have you
noticed this it's like always New York I
think to LA and then I'm going to London
and I'm gonna be in Milan I'm coming
back from Peru oh you're actually on a
higher-caliber I've got a girl leggy
coming to Newark
[Laughter]
there's one girl I was kind of in love
with uptown who are you Brooklyn right
so let me know when you're in Manhattan
yeah yes exactly
Milan good lord no Milan is a restaurant
downtown oh oh sorry
where's the girl there was a girl I
really like she was a beautiful model
that's what she would never send me
updated me know your name I'm trying to
find her because it's like from
two-and-a-half years ago and then she
came to New York but she was shady so
I'm like it was either a [ __ ]
account or as you were trying to [ __ ]
her get swooped in and nailed it
yeah I did she answered me in French
yeah picture for wet vagina my first
action in America by the way [ __ ]
blocking is really so obvious and you
know like yeah very clear you know yeah
she was really cute they didn't try to
be nuanced with this one right now [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] block there's no nuance no and
I guess it's hard to [ __ ] block if the
girl is really into you yeah I'm so
[ __ ] horrible though I've talked to a
couple of different women outside the
cellar in the last month or two and I
thought it was going really well I'm
talking to one girl for like 20 minutes
and she was a nurse and she was really
cute and we had a great conversation and
then she's talking about black guy comes
over who she knew
and then we're chatting and I turn to
talk to Wilson Vince I turn around
they're gone
no I'm like what happened and was ago I
guess they went somewhere together what
like I [ __ ] I just hate being alive I
try and I strike out that's literally my
life I mean jeez I could've been a
kidnapping I she kidnapped him believe
me if I saw the way she was looking I
know it wasn't his fault
well I want to go [ __ ] him in an alley
not just some dude you might be a
musician which musicians Trump comedians
every time oh yeah again later Jerry
level if your Seinfeld level and you're
a low-level musician but a musician will
trump a comedian every time I don't care
how good my set is I don't care how big
of a fan they are if a guy walks up with
a drumstick in his hand it will [ __ ] him
while I'm watching guy comes up with a
harmonica
no but it's one drumstick yeah forget it
I'm sorry
well that's a good thing to do you're
going to bar with one drum swirl it like
a drum yeah and then I'm sorry I dropped
yeah I don't I tried it with a triangle
it didn't work no triangle that doesn't
work
Trump's comedian though you know nobody
at this just my experience you know it's
discouraged me so because I've been
trying like and I'm being you know
having fun conversations and not trying
to [ __ ] him just being nice and it's
just one nonsensical interaction after
another another one from Dubai I talked
to I just started talking to her after a
show and she went Dubai
no he's before a show it was after one
show so I thought she saw my set I was
in between shows of the cellar so
outside it was beautiful I'm talking
about Jim you know with you we don't
know if you're you know you know this we
had this conversation before we don't
know what Jim is veestrate know yeah Jim
doesn't know everything once you talk to
us or no yeah yeah you can be tough to
jam with people have told me that and
I'm surprised to hear and I'm telling
you and now that I know you oh you're
he's the sweetest man even yeah a little
too much but I'm you know I'm
questioning now but you know you could
be hard to read then you can be a dick
you know I've been told that and I but I
didn't noted that I was like that I
didn't realize I would walk in and
people would said like I didn't know if
who told me that Sam Morril or
than you they'd say like I didn't know
if you like me I'm like no I like you a
lot like I just I think I'm is just a
[ __ ] I'm just a nervous wreck to like
I'm not good at so in the morning and I
seem at the cellar at night and he just
passes it Hey yeah that's Jim I just say
hello and I get in and I get out tonight
I always feel like after he gave me a
kiss and the hug that was too much you
know he has no balance right right it's
dreams yeah all the time
I feel like people don't want to talk to
me it's not no but I surely when I'm in
the cellar I feel like I don't want to
bother people I want to say yeah I'll
just talk but I'm weird around people
I've known for 20 years the problem we
get the people who do who we don't want
to talk to and they sit with us right
that's that's how so yeah the people
that you don't want to talk with hate
questions questions the worst human
comics yeah questions I don't want to
questions I hate when people just grill
you immediately so where have you been
what are you up to what are you working
on who books that I can take have you
been are you on the road oh yeah I can
do that because that starts something
and we also have a whole we have things
that we say every night at this hour AVO
every comics it's like are you around
the corner are you gonna be I'm here how
is the crowd yes
did you eat what do you have right is it
good for one year we've been talking
about the kitchen do you remember that
oh yeah when's it coming back what's the
menu like they were making you think
they're gonna move the table yeah it's
horse [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] Pinal chatter
but it's just something you do everyone
has it at work that was ours
that was hard just talking about the
kitchen who the worst is when somebody
will talk about ask you a question just
to segue into their own [ __ ] company
that they think is on the rise it's like
take your deal and shove it up your ass
you're going nowhere I don't [ __ ]
care so you know you know now he's out
in LA where you say that because this is
exactly what I think that I cannot well
you said crafted this I'm a nice sweet
man persona whereas he is a degenerate
lunatic but I don't say that to people
either I mean I'm as much of a [ __ ] sir
I don't say that I don't say thank you
we all think and then when the guy
phoebs ago can you believe this piece of
garbage I don't want to hear it when
they use their question to bounce
themselves into prosperity and I hate ya
I'm not interested but also not only
with comedians people Yeah right then
they won't even let you finish and
they're like oh that's funny cuz I went
to ya Hawaii I don't know yeah yeah
Louise got that great joke where the guy
comes up with let me ask you if time
machines were real what would you do and
Louise like well I think I goes let me
tell you what I would do you're like
well that's the only reason you asked me
yeah just tell me the [ __ ] thing
that is the only reason they asked to it
you're basically a [ __ ] trampoline
into their story all right he set
himself up for historians yeah like in
the talk show when they do it too
obvious too yeah yeah so here you have a
dog yeah yeah yes exactly sure do that
yeah with a movie Patrice would do that
with movies because he liked to talk
about who's the best bad guy like having
these weird movie chats but he would
call you oh he would in the car and he
would just say like you know who's your
favorite bad guy dammit were the best
villains just tell me who you're like
yeah I don't chambered cuz you're gonna
say who you like and then he's just he's
gonna have a lot of things to say here's
that shocking part if you watch guy in
France a TV host who would set you up
for the joke but almost tell the joke
but like everything all the whole thing
you know so god ah you don't like it
when you go skiing and someone is behind
you but they're holding and there's
nothing left
yes right we have that guy to Byron
Allen that guy seamless to get you into
a bit I'm telling you I'm like how does
he know I went scuba diving this guy
yeah yeah you know what though Byron
Allen is secretly like a billionaire
what a genius this guy is he owns you
know he is he's black guy he's used to
show called real people I think many
years ago with Sam Purcell and was a
comics comics unleashed that he hosted
that but he wanted Network he's a
brilliant guy really good really this
man there he is
still looks like he's [ __ ] 30 years
old any Python now I think Kevin Hart
modeled
bitingly LOL he learned a lot from Byron
Allen I'm gonna we have Kevin coming and
I'm gonna ask him if he sat down with
Byron Allen for a couple because this
guy is a really smart dude oh yeah yeah
he has he's a famous norm skit or he was
on normals on his show no McDonald he
goes so norm I hear you're getting older
and norm goes yeah we all are
he thought he's gonna set him up for a
big bit by the open heart that was in
Paris a few days ago he did a show there
was it honey a lot of comics now come to
do their show they perform in English in
Paris
well Kevin is such a movie star he can
do it anywhere you know me Kevin can
perform anywhere because people who
speak English know him he's just such a
huge celebrity story yeah yeah yeah but
speaking of norm I mean Norma's on
Howard yesterday and I read the
transcript of some of what he said and
it's it's crazy how like he was kind of
saying how you think I'm paraphrasing
about Rose Ann getting fired you know or
Louie like this experience that they
share of having everything taken away
from you yeah and he had Louie caller
and then he had to apologize because
again he's just talking and sometimes
when you're saying something are you
defending a friend you don't say it the
way you would want to see it in print so
then he has to say sorry and then he
goes you have to have down syndrome to
think that me too isn't a good thing and
then they got Marilyn for saying that
let's eat you and then he backed up and
he said like hey man I never defended
Louie like it's just it's a it's a
[ __ ] quagmire trying to say something
where it's like a mud pit it's it's a
[ __ ] a sinkhole
yeah like guy question yeah and the more
you wiggle the more you sink and they
look could I see wigglin they'd love to
watch it right good for Netflix all for
not canceling his show that should not
cancel oh [ __ ] well he just has an
opinion like he's not we're actively he
did something you know he didn't hurt
anybody and he told the story of how
Fallon who was in an awkward spot but
not really you're an interviewer yes
bear would have had him on and discussed
it so Jimmy comes I'm gonna read what
norm said happens you statement tonight
said we all know they tape it like five
something he goes Jimmy comes to me and
he goes how should we play this so the
norm said I think we should say it at
the end because if you say at the
beginning you can't come back from that
I don't do a good Norman uh-huh I heat
day and that was what he said which
meant that the news might not have been
completely but you know do it at the end
and then he goes uh what am I supposed
to ask this is what Jimmy says 2-norm
know jeez and then norm said Jimmy I
don't exactly know which was almost too
honest an answer he should have come up
with something that was normal do you
have you should have come up with
something that Fallon would have been
comfortable with right well let's talk
about you can ask me this like whatever
you want about the show that will get me
into it and then someone suggested that
he started with an apology which was you
know jeez like it's not my show Jimmy
comes back in and he goes hey can I talk
to you and he was very broken up and he
goes I don't know what to do and the
norm go should I not do the show and
Jimmy goes I don't know it's just that I
have so much pressure from so many
people people are crying normally as
people are crying and he goes yeah
senior producers are crying oh what a
hunk of [ __ ] and then norm goes well
good lord bring him here let me talk I
don't want to make people cry so Jimmy
said come back whenever you want but I
think it will hurt the show tonight and
he goes Jimmy I don't I guess those guys
know each other for a long time
first of all I don't necessarily believe
that senior producers were crying if
you're a senior producer on an NBC show
and you're weeping because Norma Donald
didn't give the most well thought-out
defense of Louie and Roseanne yeah I
think you have emotional problems that
go way beyond this situation yeah if
you're crying now if you're Harvey
Weinstein is coming on sure and it's
sparking some sort of a horrible jared
fogle
yeah somebody who is behaved in a
terrible way yeah Kevin Spacey a guy
who's been accused of under whatever
Roman Polanski uh-huh then maybe not
tapped into something yeah that might
tap into something that gets you upset
but if Norm's said something ill-advised
to The Hollywood Reporter and that is
causing you as a senior producer to cry
you should examine your sadness reflex
yes your sadness reflex is too sensitive
yeah look Norma Connells said that about
you know he didn't give the best
defensive luisa Jesus Christ get a
[ __ ] hold of yourself yeah right
you're a grown-up Norman's not accused
of anything
comic talking about his friends yeah and
also in print deals and work is his
delivery is so important and he comes
always a Canadian aloof I'm a fun guy
and even if he didn't say it the best
way and yeah at least he came out and he
said he was he was defending any comers
I'd say he was sorry he said I'm sorry
you know I wasn't shy I'm behind me to
always look what do you want the guy to
do and we want the perfectly crafted
zero offensive yet sincere apology so we
don't want it to sound like you came
from a [ __ ] lawyer but we wanted to
have the heartfelt genuineness yeah but
in heartfelt genuineness sometimes you
say something that is not perfectly
crafted as you're speaking from the
heart I disagree I think if you have a
perfect analogy won't man I think they
want you to grovel they want you to just
beg for forgiveness on your knees
you know what norms stick we have norms
apology and this is why I'm saying this
because his apology was pretty genuine
ya know it's a good apology but they
didn't care
of course what I'm saying they didn't
blood yeah well yeah they do one blood
he comes in to shoot his norm said and
the norm is not a [ __ ] guy who comes
out in brothels and apologizes he's a
pretty harsh comic man and Louis have
both been good friends of mine for many
years they both made terrible mistakes
and I would never defend their actions
if my words sounded like I was
minimizing the pain that their victims
feel to this day I am deeply sorry
beautiful what would you like I mean
Roseanne didn't have any victims but I
know what I'm saying well what would you
like norm to say yeah but that wasn't
after that The Tonight Show still pulled
him off yeah what the [ __ ] do you want
this guy to say I know also there's a
cool side of this where he's having
compassion for the people who were his
friends these are his friend he's gonna
defend them and everybody just like kill
them ruin their lives and he's the only
one going oh I know her she's not racist
yeah how about the sailor you don't how
come the same people aren't attacking
Camille Cosby I mean or I mean ycs wife
divorced him but anyone anyone who stays
with their spouse who's been accused of
bad thing why aren't these [ __ ]
people attacking any actor that's worked
with Roman Polanski after knowing would
stop yeah what do you Alan they all
claim to hey but then they all do his
movies what he's different because what
he's only one accuser
even though I do kind of believe her but
with woody there was no there's no
reason in a very very I think he nailed
it I mean that's there's nothing you can
add to that no I think he said it
it seems pretty sincere and he wrote it
himself and that's out of character for
norm to say something like this so you
know he means it you know it became it's
not about what you feel and you want to
say it's I want you they expect you to
say something specific you know it's
like today on the social media it's not
about oh he said that is it's good for
us to misunderstand it's almost like oh
we pretend we misunderstood yeah you
know we have that in Europe too you have
made some friends write something and
it's not that they didn't understand
it's it's how would you say um come on
to this Ali's a conscious oh that's easy
it's a purposeful misunderstanding yeah
it's like no week we got what he wants
to say but this is not gonna be this
there will be no blood with that let's
make something else you can use this to
[ __ ] you're not we can use this and you
get some very big show with charity in
France if they have a concert it's
called little soiree big you know big
telethon you know and then yeah I
tweeted it's great to be here long life
too and then the organization mm-hm and
I got in trouble for months why cuz I
said long life to this organization
which means to them long life to poverty
long life to come I mean while you're
saying the organization is great long
life to the people who are fighting this
yes and let's keep on being did you know
together and find a but the thing is
today
they don't misunderstand they're
organizing they like guys how can we
[ __ ] this exactly how is there a way we
can like there like this is there What
did he say how can we spin it yeah
exactly they want to stay why the
outrage just come on people are not
crazy they know I was never aware
you know well I'm disagreeing with you I
think that we should continue poverty I
would have been I would have been bad
mouth of the organization and praising
the idea of poverty that's important
saying that yeah they're poor I'm rich
absolutely and then your friends
tomorrow have you heard this guy Jim
Norton everyone will go no that's all
most of America yeah nah not at all it
gives them something to do it gives them
a personality look I'm a hero I'm
outraged yeah but nothing really
happened great so I'm good
don't even care about stopping racism or
stop talking about even meat I had a
joke about meat one day so I can I can
we make fun with the me to know the
vegans oh yeah yeah normally the things
are known for their humor which is kind
of okay with me oh yeah they're known
for good humor funny people very funny I
mean they do enjoy a good animal jokes
you know the handle where they don't
immediately get serious to talk about
cruelty they just enjoy a good dog they
love it a good good witticism about it
but it just feels like there's more
emphasis now on punishing we want to
punish punish how about educate educate
let's help people to make them think
let's discuss how about neither how
about just make jobs and [ __ ] laugh
or don't laugh suppose your options
mother fire
laugh or look at me yeah option for the
joke don't see my show you don't see my
show yeah [ __ ] cut your dumb ears off
I know it's [ __ ] van Gogh had the
right idea van Gogh is probably gonna
offend it as a joke and then realize all
I'm a dick right here off and threw it
in the ocean we're all gonna die one day
this is what you want to put your time
into exactly some of us will die tonight
at 9:40 by the way completely off the
subject mark is is that safe I see
bustle outside buddy never seen this guy
in the day - how are you guys good to
see you no no we're just sorry
we're gonna go to break in like 15
minutes but you always want to go to
break once an hour we have it that's
let's let's snow I urinate I have to
piss we can keep going welcome thanks
hey thanks for having me you all come so
you got a
two good guys here yeah yeah good guy
and then our self-esteem we talked we
talked before not gonna hate you Amelia
you walk in but Bob bombing stories cuz
I like we me and March started this
morning talking about it oh great last
night did you eat your dick last night
yeah but it was it was a weird one why
it was okay so you know I also do improv
UCB I love great improv yeah good job TV
show was working on Alicia Keys was my
executive producer Wow he's very famous
no I know she's the most beautiful and
talented and brilliant than money feek
yeah she's more than that I'm sorry
ciao he's French so today's Swizz Beatz
birthday her husband so last night they
had this crazy party like a Casino
Royale set up this beautiful venue it
they had casino tables craps and
blackjack and roulette and they're like
there we want to sing him happy birthday
and then we want you to come out and do
an improv show he loves my improv show
he did my show once I get I usually get
rappers to tell stories and then we do
an improv show based on their story okay
boy I told her about it and that she
wanted to do a TV show would be way she
wanted to do an improv show and a
birthday I'd rather do one of the
child's wake it's a horrible place no
yes no way I would say it doesn't see
this is we've had this discussion before
Jim I'm a hustle I know you get in the
room I guess you'd done an hour right
come on
can you move his that other Mike
Robinson note it was disgustingly Harv
okay so what
that of course are they all talking when
you go on here so there's no everyone
saying no I want to know what you did
what you did what did you play what did
you I was so like okay so everyone's
standing in like gals and tuxedo
they sing happy birthday and like
Christian Louboutin was there
I know Christian yeah Christian
Louboutin was there and a bunch of other
like there's like Swiss his hood family
on the left and like multi millionaires
and billionaires on the right I'm like
what so who are you I got like like four
people with me like Casey Jost
oh yeah Joe's brother couple other guys
and gals nah yeah so we get Swizz Beatz
mom to come on stage and tell a little
story about about Swiss growing up so we
could use that as inspiration sure yeah
I mean did they like her story who heard
it nobody were they talking while his
mother was loudly talking well the
birthday guy's mother is talking you
don't do the imposture so it's basically
an urban show with improv yes which
doesn't work so she told a little story
well they're all chatting how many
people were there how many people I had
to be like 300 people by the way if you
this is the thing if you if your story
was what a great improv show I had last
night that would've been the end of this
discussion but the fact that it was [ __ ]
I look I want to milk this for how long
10 minutes all I'm gonna call this John
Luther
the type of show did you see the guy who
did improv is I'm gonna say no did you
text him do you don't want to text him
if you could text him I would love to
know how could he what did you say what
did you do I want to know so they so we
do is like we get the story and I was
about Swizz Beatz he he left home oh one
of the beats was like she you say DMX
always used to come to our house and eat
up all her food so somebody played DMX
coming in and asking like making orders
like it was a restaurant but it was
Swizz Beatz mom's huh why this sounds
like a perfect fodder for an evening of
entertainment standing costumes improv
the typing problem is just you got
but listen honey show was supposed to be
25 minutes give me a suggestion stop
this show wasn't even eight minutes the
show was I went up there and improv
while nobody paid who was it now where's
Alicia and her husband stand there
trying to be encouraging yeah and then
Tiffany Haddish came onstage afterwards
that helps I was like tiffany has come
that was last night last night cuz she
was at the show I did yeah every a lot
of people can't you did the Seinfeld a
lot of people came from there yeah they
were all dressed up you know what I was
trying to do and they they were my [ __ ]
to your show yeah so you so so they saw
who's on your show you Seinfeld
Sebastian Seth Meyers right they which
is a beautiful novel comedic experience
to a [ __ ] show John Legend was there
disgusting so wait you went up on stage
now who was watching you trying to be
encouraging in the front
what celebrity tapped out immediately
how long did Alesha last before you
could see on her face did she hate it
she well she smiled she obviously hated
it but she encouraged she's a nice
person she was lying though the show
snow it's 2,000 percent thanks for doing
this I know it was rough and I was this
thing I said back in the day shows like
this make you not ever want to go
onstage again but now we all just laugh
about yeah yeah and it's improv it was a
[ __ ] show how many of you are there how
many improv mean and a four others Fivey
I've never eaten my dick with five other
that might be okay if there's a bunch of
you [ __ ] the bed together it alone
it would be horrible
yeah five people it's like an orgy that
can't get it up yeah like a corporate
event or something and everyone is
having but corporates are my actual
bread and butter
what do you mean I do great in
corporates and they're all no no mark is
right no I don't
exactly but you should have done steps
the beauty of stand-up because if it's
going we're gonna be like well this is
weird
oh boy it's the horrible I am probably
gonna pretend like it's the same which I
definitely broke the walls like I hope I
go hey I go I end the show that's not
show
happy birthday Swizz Beatz now that
anyone's [ __ ] listening to me that's
our show happy / let me ask you how far
into the bus oh what a weird how far
into do you realize is he gonna stop DMX
this girl named X okay what would that
she did DMX ordering food did he get a
laugh I was trying to listen it was so
rude I was like what you really want
baloney you say that because last night
yes I had a great joy it was great but
one night when he finished the show was
so happy about the show I just one thing
I wanted to do is go to the cellar and
do one set yeah clean yourself going in
the pot you know you know what I'm
talking about how but it was good though
the event yeah it was good I just what
does it feel it's just big and you know
this huge room not stuffy but it's like
also when you do charity events it's
like people have this this vibe about
him because it's like well this is for a
good cause so I'm a good person
Gary events i bombed that [ __ ] yes
cancer charities animal charities only
[ __ ] it would take the disease I never
do well at charities hate me I don't
know if you know who Angie Martinez is
she's a famous radio personality she's
like my mentor she was like oh I just
came from this Jerry Seinfeld thump
she's like oh my god there was this
[ __ ] Italian guy doesn't matter how
big you are people still don't know
nobody knows me
yeah because unions oh yeah every time I
do a show I like you see how these
screens say Jim Norton and Sam Roberts I
always put the names of the comedian's
on the screens I got the cellar if I do
like a produce show cuz and I put their
you know their Instagram or Twitter you
know I understand that but you guys
don't realize cuz you here you live here
I've moved here and I and I see you know
how many comedians are here it's so many
of them yeah and to Mike even in the top
names in America you can say maybe 50 of
them yeah or maybe no I can tell you
maybe three guys in in Europe right
really we shared the market right there
must be so many poor is it that one
tight but how great is that you get to
stand out here where a dime a dozen
of course Wow they imagined me coming
here who are you what the [ __ ] are you
what do you want
you have already complicated we're here
with the American right I'm not gonna I
don't want to be rude but gab you can be
rude with me Dad ruins shows at the
cellar
oh come on Kay because you I didn't look
at the lineup the other night when I was
hosting when you came on but if you look
at the lineup and see God's name just
know there's about 60 or 70 French
people in the audience that don't give a
[ __ ] about anything else except seeing
God okay so so GAD goes on and afters I
go hey you French cheese you can't leave
now you have to stay can I tell you
something yeah uh it's it's it's it's a
good thing to hear but I don't like it
what they come for you yeah different
name no because yeah I'm gonna do that
some comedians do that yeah they do
but what about Joe Goodman don't
Goodman's that sounds like a celebrity
name that come in just to see Joe
Goodman no but I understand what are you
saying but I don't like John Casey's a
good name
you know what I what I love Sipho I
really love when no one knows me
so you want to be Jim Norton will come
up with a name for you right now a fake
name is my real name can you be Luis
Diaz is that your real name Oh
dia Z I'm already entrenched inside an
improv show you might want to change it
yes ciphers like is that hip-hop name
cypher means like 360 degrees it's a
stupid name
it's not like a five percenter thing
yeah it is can we put the music when he
talks like that like they do in the in
the Oscars and no in not the music
because you're done the music hip-hop
radios they always have a soundtrack
going behind it's great I love it dad
has to leave for some reason I'm not I'm
not saying that stay with you guys okay
I want to talk with the music when I'm
in LA I'm listening to I'm listening to
this radio 105.9 yeah power one of our
power yeah
is that what this is yeah so much Tiger
Tiger taste - yeah I didn't know by the
way I like the original tiger that
Jamaican tiger
look how cool we are talking on the
music I love it I like this guy I think
we almost bump noses over a penis my
last name properly I always say el
mulatto male but he really focus well
male when he brings me on at this hour I
see him very focusing and how do you say
what's the problem and I show you this
guy no I'm gonna lose their last name
just got is good that's what I just go
again yeah that's it last name now I
need those young any marks yeah no sizes
Lord Jim that's when you really made it
though and you can just be like Oh
Sarah's here Sarah so
Kelvin AK yeah there's a lot of gyms
sure are
they'll help it's Gaffigan jim carrey
right any white people a lot I went to
high school in Long Island so I know how
to speak white so don't get offended all
right well a lot of white people your
nickname is just your last name yeah
they're like Norman yeah Norma Donna's
here
no it's just normo there's a lot of
nicknames yeah that's because it's in
quotes as a nickname that's fair I knew
your book right yeah no Norton IQ it's
funny people have called me on or tone
sign felted that when I walk till he
goes noir tone and I've been having my
whole life people have said that I don't
know why they make that jump I've gotten
that for years kids in France they would
call us at school in school that was
caused by our last name and you would
have to write your last name first
you know like on your yes ass or
something you'd have to write Norton Jim
that's kind of common way of my coche in
Europe and we had to fill out the form
at at the hotel and it goes sir what's
your what's your surname heels which was
the surname the first name is what last
name his last name yeah s you are not a
French sore no no I don't know I just
last name sounds like the last name we
the first time I heard that it's like
your last name that's the last name
you're gonna